Imagine a big explosion
as you climb through 3,000 ft.
Imagine a plane full of smoke.
Imagine an engine
going clack, clack, clack.
It sounds scary.
Well, I had a unique seat that day.
I was sitting in 1D.
I was the only one who could talk
to the flight attendants.
So I looked at them right away,
and they said, "No problem.
We probably hit some birds."
The pilot had already
turned the plane around,
and we weren't that far.
You could see Manhattan.
Two minutes later,
three things happened at the same time.
The pilot lines up the plane
with the Hudson River.
That's usually not the route.
(Laughter)
He turns off the engines.
Now, imagine being
in a plane with no sound.
And then he says three words.
The most unemotional
three words I've ever heard.
He says, "Brace for impact."
I didn't have to talk
to the flight attendant anymore.
(Laughter)
I could see in her eyes, it was terror.
Life was over.
Now I want to share with you three things
I learned about myself that day.
I learned that it
all changes in an instant.
We have this bucket list,
we have these things
we want to do in life,
and I thought about all the people
I wanted to reach out to that I didn't,
all the fences I wanted to mend,
all the experiences I wanted
to have and I never did.
As I thought about that later on,
I came up with a saying,
which is, "I collect bad wines."
Because if the wine is ready
and the person is there, I'm opening it.
I no longer want to postpone
anything in life.
And that urgency, that purpose,
has really changed my life.
The second thing I learned that day --
and this is as we clear
the George Washington Bridge,
which was by not a lot --
(Laughter)
I thought about, wow,
I really feel one real regret.
I've lived a good life.
In my own humanity and mistakes,
I've tried to get better
at everything I tried.
But in my humanity,
I also allow my ego to get in.
And I regretted the time I wasted
on things that did not matter
with people that matter.
And I thought about
my relationship with my wife,
with my friends, with people.
And after, as I reflected on that,
I decided to eliminate
negative energy from my life.
It's not perfect, but it's a lot better.
I've not had a fight
with my wife in two years.
It feels great.
I no longer try to be right;
I choose to be happy.
The third thing I learned --
and this is as your mental clock
starts going, "15, 14, 13."
You can see the water coming.
I'm saying, "Please blow up."
I don't want this thing
to break in 20 pieces
like you've seen in those documentaries.
And as we're coming down,
I had a sense of, wow, dying is not scary.
It's almost like we've been preparing
for it our whole lives.
But it was very sad.
I didn't want to go; I love my life.
And that sadness
really framed in one thought,
which is, I only wish for one thing.
I only wish I could see my kids grow up.
About a month later,
I was at a performance by my daughter --
first-grader, not much artistic talent --
(Laughter)
Yet!
And I'm bawling,
I'm crying, like a little kid.
And it made all the sense
in the world to me.
I realized at that point,
by connecting those two dots,
that the only thing
that matters in my life
is being a great dad.
Above all, above all,
the only goal I have in life
is to be a good dad.
I was given the gift of a miracle,
of not dying that day.
I was given another gift,
which was to be able
to see into the future
and come back
and live differently.
I challenge you guys
that are flying today,
imagine the same thing
happens on your plane --
and please don't --
but imagine, and how would you change?
What would you get done
that you're waiting to get done
because you think you'll be here forever?
How would you change your relationships
and the negative energy in them?
And more than anything,
are you being the best parent you can?
Thank you.
(Applause)